hello and welcome to a week 15 edition
of The Bleacher Report fantas football
show presented by State Farm my name is
Adam Levitan of establish the run.com as
always joined by Michael Leone of
establish the run.com to get you set get
your fantasy team set for some people's
first round of their playoffs I assume
some people scrapping fighting clong to
get into the playoffs hopefully you've
already clinched a playoff spot and are
getting your stashes squared away your
quicker stream
your DST streamer squared away Leone
how's it going on this fine Thursday
afternoon good excited for the fantasy
playoffs for sure and uh made it in a
few of my local leagues and in some of
the higher Stakes contests so excited to
see how that plays out oh for sure let's
start here wait for some more people to
file in here we'll get to some questions
Adam montali says Kiren Williams has to
be a must start right oh buddy Adam
you're cooking with gas if you have
Kiren man I mean it's hard to think of a
better running back role right now
obviously Christian mcaffrey comes to
mind but Kiron Williams has one of the
best roles in the entire NFL and he's
facing the Cardinals and you have very
competent quarterback play in Matthew
Stafford I mean you couldn't find a much
better spot for kir Williams so shout
out to you might as well just go ahead
and put 25 points into your lineup right
now with Kiren Williams Ian says Odell
Beckham or Jaylen Wadd so so I mean this
Odell stuff he went from playing like
30% of the snaps to 50% of the snaps but
when he's out there Lamar loves throwing
to Odell Beckham and honestly I'm an
Odell hater he's looked really good the
last few weeks I couldn't bring myself
to play Odell Beckham over Jaylen Wadd
personally but maybe it's not as crazy
as it sounds Leone any thoughts on this
one yeah I mean it's definitely trending
great for Odell but end of the day I got
to go jayen Wadd and there's also you
know we'll see what's up with Tyreek
health status too but if he's Limited at
all we could see some more Target share
for Jaylen Wadd and um yeah I just think
the amount of routes that he's running
in that offense supersedes what Odell
has done I know Odell has run super pure
and I do like him but he has to continue
to hit on these big plays to pay off
because he's still not playing like you
know his Target volume is still not
going to be that that high uh I'm not
sure if you're aware what's going on
here Leone uh this was actually not a
random audience question this was from
Ian Evans producer at Bleacher Report
who snuck in a personal question here my
God all right on today's show we are GNA
go over some of our favorite sneakier
starts for this week or maybe some guys
that you guys might be on the fence
about we're going to do six of those we
also hit our State Farm top five bundles
of the week so let's get into it here
and start with the Fantasy Playoff must
starts we'll start start with the game
tonight ad o Connell will reportedly be
starting I understand ad o Connell has
been really bad he's had some difficult
matchups this matchup here against the
Chargers in clean weather is one of the
better matchups you can get at this
point in the NFL for an opposing pass
game Devonte Adams has been up and down
I would say but I just expect better
offensive efficiency as a whole and you
get Josh Jacobs quad issue so you get
even more leaning in towards the ask
here I think it makes a lot of sense for
them to lean into Devonte Adams tonight
so I know it's been bad for Devonte
Adams if you have him I would be
starting him tonight Leon any thoughts
on Devonte and then you can go ahead to
our second must start for the fantasy
playoffs yeah really expect him to get
fed you know he's been able to produce
with subpar quarterback play before and
I I think that continues so I'm with him
as a start and sticking with wide
receiver goaz Jones is our number two
must start for the fantasy playoffs and
with Christian Kirk out last week we saw
an extremely condensed target tree for
Trevor Lawrence Z Jones actually LED all
receivers with a 28% Target share you
had Evan Ingram at 24% Calvin Ridley at
26% so expect to see more of the same
this week it's a gross matchup against
Baltimore uh but it was a gross match up
for them against Cleveland too which
just might mean they're gonna have to
throw a whole lot we're more concerned
with the volume than the efficiency at
the wide receiver position so go ahead
and slot in Z Jones yeah I I it's not
the best matchup at a home game against
the Ravens I think that Z Jones can
actually win uh in that match up and
Trevor Lawrence can actually win in that
matchup so yeah certainly like going
back to Z Jones off the 14 targets get
some chats that are here hopefully from
some actual uh listeners we'll start
with M Hernandez says he needs two out
of three in standard for those you guys
who don't know standard is a prehistoric
version of fantasy in which you don't
get any points for receptions you only
get points for for uh touchdowns no I'm
joking so uh Garrett Wilson Rashid
Rashid rice or Z flers here in standard
we're hunting for touchdowns Leone
obviously when we're talking about
touchdowns you can make a case that the
Chiefs are the best bet to score
touchdown every week however these days
Chiefs aren't scoring that many
touchdowns every week so what do you
think about this one Wilson Rashid rice
or Mr
flowers I do still think you know the
Chiefs are the best bet for passing
touchdowns and Rashi rice we've been
waiting for his role to expand and it
kind of was a little bit they yo-yoed us
and then finally he got above 80% route
share and I mean everybody else on this
team has just been disappointing at the
wide receiver position for Kanas City so
good team total New England's defense
much better against the Run than against
the pass so I do like Rashid rice in a
standard form really in any format among
those three wide receivers Minnie Wolf
says Ezekiel Elliott or chuba hubard I
mean you know I have no problem with
Zeke as a person my issue was when Zeke
was in Dallas it was so frustrating to
watch him blob around out there and
struggle and then see Tony po come in
and just rip it up and then they'd go
back to Ezekiel Elliott you know and it
doesn't look great now because Tony P
hasn't had a great year but that was
very frustrating I need to get over my
bias now because the way the Patriots
are using Ezekiel Elliott is outrageous
I mean we're talking about Kyrie
Williams C C type stuff now difficult
matchup Pates are not going to score a
lot of points here against the Chiefs
but I still think I would go Zeke over
chuba hubard here it's not like the
Panthers are scoring many touchdowns
either so think it's pretty easily Zeke
here Leone any thoughts on Zeke or
chuba uh just the workload for Zeke has
been so awesome it's it does feel like a
cruel trick from the fantasy Gods to
dump Zeke as an important player and
passet of the fantasy playoffs but as
you said got to put the bias aside um
let's go to low who asks zamir white or
James Conor and yeah that's the tough
one we got Josh Jacobs out tonight we
are expecting most of the twood down
rooll to go to zamir white but do think
Amir Abdullah is gonna work in in the
pass game
so that's a tough one for me I think I
might go zamir with the it's a bit of a
gross game but I think the overall
touches and how down the Chargers are
right now that he might be the slightly
better pick here
yeah I might go Connor just because I
have no idea what zamir White's exact
role is going to be tonight you know and
you could show up and you could get away
you could come out of this game with
like 10 zamir white touches and I'd
rather have 10 Z James Conor touches I
think even against San Francisco but
super close one there for sure R RoR
says Noah brown or Amari Cooper so this
is gonna be a tough one to answer till
we know the status of CJ strad and Nico
Collins I think for now I would expect
CJ strad out and Nico Collins probably
out as well um Noah
brown with Davis Mills I would not want
to play so I think this is going to be
Amari Cooper for me but certainly keep
an eye on the injury report also just if
we're going based on Talent Amari Cooper
is way ahead Annie says Brandon Cooks or
Sam leapor here Leone so tight end
versus wide receiver discussions are
always interesting typically I think
wide receivers that provide a higher
ceiling but volume concerns on Brandon
Cooks I think are always there what do
you think about Cooks against your bills
or Mr
leapa yeah you hit the volume concerns
for cook shift this to leapa for me
Detroit actually has a higher team total
than Dallas this week given their home
against Denver I know Denver's defense
has been much improved over the course
of the season but again a 26 team total
in a dome uh is going to play better
than Dallas going on the road in playing
in and outdoor and environment and
leaport more base volume to begin with
so um yeah Cooks has a big ceiling
because he can get down the field and
make those big plays but absent of that
it's hard for him to outproduce Sam
pora last chat here before we get back
to our starts would be from Cole
Fletcher Cole says jome Ford or DeAndre
Hopkins so you saw DeAndre Hopkins and
will Levis really come to life late in
that Monday night game this spot against
Houston I mean probably no Will Anderson
here I mean Houston's falling apart a
little bit I kind of like this spot for
DeAndre Hopkins but any thoughts on this
one
Leone yeah I like this spot for DeAndre
Hopkins as well we've definitely seen
the upside with Will lvis at quarterback
a lot more touchdown upside and you know
lvis is gonna stand in there deliver the
ball down the field so I prefer him to
Jerome Ford Ford also kind of a tough
run matchup against this Chicago Bears
defense all right let's get back now to
we'll get to some more chats later but
for now let's get back to our Fantasy
Playoff must start so far we have
Damonte Adams and Z Jones let's go back
to that Tennessee Houston game so I only
really want to play at this point in his
career Derrick Henry when I'm confident
the Titans are gonna have a lead because
otherwise you get a lot of Taj Spears
and I think everybody saw that on Monday
night assuming Davis Mills is in we know
tank Dell is out CJ stoud likely out
Nico Collins probably out it's actually
a good spot for the Titans to get a lead
and get a lead through Derrick Henry so
I understand that people have been on
the fence and it's been bad at times for
Derrick Henry this would actually be a
spot where I like starting Derk Henry so
I would if you have Derrick Henry I
would have him in my lineup here home
game against the Texans Leon go ahead
with our next one yeah Matthew Stafford
is our next one and we have a DVP tool
over to establish to run that kind of
tries to predict how bad moving forward
a defense will be in terms of allowing
fantasy points to a specific position
and we have Washington as the most
favorable quarterback matchup for
opposing quarterbacks Stafford has his
pass catcher healthy now with puka and
cup there it's looking really good it's
another Dome game too you know n the
weather spots look too bad but that's
always a nice little tiebreaker so um
and the amount of explosive plays
Washington has allowed this season to
offenses of all kinds is really out of
control the fact that they'll also throw
with Sam Hall no matter what puts the
other team in advantageous position
speeds up the pace of the game so a lot
of factors working for Matthew Stafford
yeah I'm sure there's people out there
that lost Justin Herbert ahead of their
fantasy playoffs which is brutal um I
think Stafford if he's available on your
wire which he may not be now but if he's
available he would be easily the best
streamer of the week is Matthew
Stafford all right couple more chats
here questions big cat says Jordan
Addison or Josh DS oh big cats rubbing
salt in the wound I have been big time
in on Josh DS the last couple weeks and
the target shares have just been spread
so much flatter than I thought they
would be a lot of tight end targets a
lot of Alec Pierce
targets I think at this point even with
Nick Mullins ah God I don't want to say
it Leone actually I'm curious what you
think first because I don't want to say
Jordan Addison but go ahead I think you
got to go back to downs we have it
projected pretty tight
but you know I just think there's a lot
more risk with Addison when you've got
Justin Jefferson back they're onto their
fourth quarterback already this season
it's not the cleanest spot on the road
in
Cincinnati I'd prefer playing you know
Downs with more stable quarterback play
in a dome even with kind of a difficult
matchup against this Pittsburgh defense
it's close but I feel a little bit
better about Downs historically you've
been able to beat Pittsburg through the
slot I mean that's been the place to
beat Pittsburgh's defense in the slot
it's not as sticky now but yeah that's a
close one DS is my guy but um yeah we'll
stick with him uh Jay chotes says
Hopkins or puka it's hard to sit puka
man I I don't think people understand
this matchup the commanders have no pass
rush no talent in their defense
secondary and they play this uh very
pass heavy style which allows other team
to run a ton of plays I can't sit puka
here I know Cooper cup bounced back and
had a good game last week I think it's
pukah uh for
sure hi 907 says DJ Moore or Evan Ingram
man if you isolate DJ Moore's games only
to the ones where Justin Fields has
played DJ Moore has been like one of the
best wide receivers in the NFL this year
for fantasy and it's painful to me
because I thought thought he was a
pretty bad pick in the preseason I do
not have a lot of DJ Moore but yeah I
think as long as Justin Fields is
playing which he is this week even
against Cleveland I'm probably playing
DJ Moore here Leon any thoughts on that
one yeah I mean as someone who also
faded DJ Moore in basically all formats
I lost my mind last week when he scored
kind of a a fluky touchdown but like you
said with Justin Fields you know we've
seen you know just the condensed Target
share especially as the season has worn
on it's difficult match match up but
it's not a good match up for Ingram
either uh you got to take DJ Moore here
and play for the
upside all right now it's time for
everybody's favorite portion of the
program it is the fantasy bundles
presented by State Farm we're bundling
your home and auto insurance is just
another way to save with the personal
price
plan so for those guys who are new we're
going to be talking here about bundles
AKA Stacks AKA teammates that work well
together this week for anyone who plays
DFS that's kind of our specialty at ET
and um you need to be stacking if you
are playing DFS
tournaments first bundle of the week is
one that we already hit on actually
Lamar Jackson to Odell Beckham Jr
quietly Jaguar secondary has been
getting flamed I mean absolutely flamed
I think Lamar has an outside chance
still to win the MVP and Odell Beckham
coming on as we talked about has been a
big part of that you removed Mark
Andrews and you also get more Reliance
on Odell Beckham here so we already
talked about the Odell spot a little bit
here but Lamar Jackson to Odell is our
first bundle of the week Le only you can
go ahead and head to our second bundle
yeah bundle two we got another MVP
candidate and Brock pie going to George
KD I feel like perie is not fully been
getting his due I know he has an awesome
scheme under Shanahan and absurd skill
player Talent around him but he has the
highest yards per attempt since CT
Warner and the greatest show on tur tied
at 9.9 which in the Super Bowl era no
other quarterback has exceeded so let's
let's give some kudos to perie and comes
at a pretty good time because this
Arizona defense is 31st in overall dvoa
31st in past dvoa only that Washington
defense that uh we said to pick on with
Matthew Stafford has been worse so uh I
think KD finds the end zone this week
little bit of you know squeaky wheel
there I know he hit the end zone last
week but it's been a lot of Debo games
the last couple of weeks I think we see
it swing back to kiddle a bit more in
terms of overall volume so just so much
upside for everybody on San Francisco
quite frankly for sure and like all
these games that are ugly backup
quarterbacks bad weather and then you
get Brock pie in an amazing matchup in
clean weather like just sticks out
massively third bundle is Russ Wilson to
Courtland Sutton so Lions defense man
wheels are off the Lions defense we're
going back like to 2020 21 2021 Lions
defense when they were like inept and
that's what we've seen lately from them
now you get a Denver offense in the Dome
on the Saturday night game courland
Sutton has been outplaying Jerry Judy
all year strikes me that Russ and Sutton
have better chemistry also strikes me
that the way Russ likes to throw AKA
those deep balls those High deep
vertical balls on go routes Sutton runs
the majority of those routes for the
Broncos so pretty good spot here for the
Broncos who are hungry for the playoffs
as a whole Russ to Sutton is our third
bundle Le only go ahead with number four
yeah plus Sutton just scores a touchdown
every week no matter what so that's uhas
that's nice um fourth bundle Gino Smith
or Drew lock to Jackson Smith and jiga I
do think it's going to be Gino it seems
like it's trending that way but lock was
honestly really exceeded expectations in
a super tough spot against San Francisco
last week they were also willing to let
him air it out so I think that's good
and speaking of airing it out you know
when you're dogs against Philly you're
going to be throwing the ball a lot one
just due to game script but two the
makeup of the Philly defense they're
much better against the Run than against
the pass as a result they have the
second highest pass right over
expectation against this season so
that's the way people choose to attack
and we've seen the targets per route run
grow for jsn over the course of the
Season we've seen his ADOT grow so
there's more upside for him than when he
was going like four for 25 at the
beginning of the year you've got you
know 681 type of upside maybe even a
little bit more than that and you never
know when DK meaf is just going to get
himself thrown out of the game for you
know going nuts on on someone on the
defense just never know all right Fifth
and Final
bundle is Derek Carr to Chris alve now
this is one that is going to make people
throw up because Chris alve has not had
a great year and Derek Carr has been
struggling and this is better if taes is
out I just think it's going to be a
pretty big let down spot for the Giants
here wi the huge emotional Monday night
game in in the Meadowlands with DeVito
and and the uh you know all the
nicknames and everything and and now
they got to get regrouped and go on the
road to a Hungary Saints team good spot
for the SA
generally and Chris has been so close to
so many huge plays all year against his
giant secondary I think he comes up with
them so Carr to Ave a sneaky stack this
week for
sure those are our bundles of the week
Lamar to Odell prie to KD Russ to Sutton
Gino to jsn and Carr to Alive let get
back into a few listener or audience
member questions here Julian 3 says to
Tua or Dak Prescott so Tyreek Hill is
hurt there's going to be a lot of wind
in Miami the Jets have one of the best
uh pass defens in the league would be an
easy Dak call for me Leon won't admit it
because he is a Bill's laundry bro AKA
Homer but it is uh pretty clearly daked
to have a better game here than Tua in
my opinion Leone even as a bills Homer
would you agree I think yeah I think
it's Dak I don't think it's close I'm
just glad we have you on tape
referencing the weather as a reason to
make a fantasy selection so we will
remember that for anyone out there who
doesn't know the back story Adam Adam Lo
the concern over the weather each week
and rightfully so last week we're all
freaking out about the Baltimore game
ended up totally fine but we get another
quarterback question highz asks fields
or
Stafford I think this is Stafford uh
maybe that's too contrarian going in the
playoffs I know Fields always has that
rushing upside but you know his sack R's
been a little bit better lately but cel
's defense is just so so dominating
Stafford in the nut matchup with the
health of Kiren Williams puka cup it's
all kind of coming together I think Higg
might even be back this week I I really
think Flor and you know ceiling maybe's
comparable but I think the floor is way
way higher on
Stafford all right M Bor says Gino Smith
Trevor Lawrence or Jake Browning so
I really like the spot for Gino it seems
like the groin is going to be an issue
and feels to me like that's something
that can be aggravated so if you wanted
to take some risk off the table I would
probably go with one of those other two
guys Lawrence against Baltimore or the
Saturday Spot Browning home against the
Vikings quietly I don't think people
realize Vikings defense has been
borderline Elite I mean they Blitz a ton
so they can give up some big plays
but I don't know about Jake brownie
against the blitz here so tough one here
Leone Gino who's banged up Lawrence in a
somewhat difficult matchup without
Christian Kirk or Browning in what I
would consider an actual difficult
matchup man I think I'd roll the dice
with Gino if he's starting I think he's
in the best spot I think I would go with
him unless you know you're real big
favorite over your opponent maybe you
just don't want you want to take the
injury risk off the table in which case
I think i' saw with Lawrence over
Browning just on Talent given neither
match Up's that great yeah one thing
that's tough there is that is a Monday
night game between the Seahawks and
Eagles and so Gino could end up a g game
time you know if it came down to it yeah
you could pick up a lock but I think I
would probably go Lawrence over over
lock uh if that was my choice um soccer
day says Odell or Jaden Reed a lot of
Odell questions here Leone people love
their Odell Beckham Odell Beckham or Mr
Reed yeah I mean good segue into our
fifth playoff must start here which is
actually jadden Reed and I'll go with
him over Odell Beckham the targets per
route run overall Target share for him
is going to be really really strong with
all the injuries that the Packers have
Christian Watson looks like AJ Dylan's
in trouble Davian Wicks hurt his ankle
last game maybe plays I think he was
practicing today but probably not at
100% so he's going to be among the top
two target guys for Green Bay and in
addition to that they just find ways to
get him the ball I think I know he had a
rushing touchdown last week I think he
might have had won a previous game too
but especially with Dylan banged up you
got to think they're going to figure out
a way to get him involved in the Run
game so he's a pretty high floor player
for Green Bay yes our fifth must start
Mr jayen Reed I kid is Awesome with the
ball in his hands I mean they get him
the ball short the end rounds the jet
sweeps really really good Sixth and
final must start is going to be a guy
that I know has frustrated people a lot
this year it's beon Robinson I feel like
Arthur Smith has seen the light a little
bit and I understand they've still been
really run heavy but I feel it just
feels like he wants to throw more he
wants to involve bejan more he wants he
sees what Drake London can do he sees
what bjan can do and slowly but surely
I'm feeling a little bit better about
the week- toe usage on beon and Drake
London now I don't want to overreact to
last week which is an awesome spot for
Drake London in my opinion this is an
awesome spot for bejan even if they go
extremely run heavy against Carolina
because they can beat Carolina any way
they want that should still be a lot of
beon so I don't know Leone I actually
meant to ask you earlier about Atlanta's
pass rate do you see any reason to think
that they Arthur is capitulating and
actually running a modern NFL audience
uh offense these days no they are
establishing it there are games where
they get behind or they just get get
behind not only in terms of score but
just in terms of the chains and that
gives them like a higher expected pass
rate but their Pro last game they're
only negative -2% the three games before
that negative 177% negative 16% negative
-22% and Tampa Bay last week's a matchup
that you know historically teams throw a
little bit more than usual so I'm not
overthinking that they were a little bit
more neutral last week now they get
Carolina and I think with Bean too he's
gotten more of the work the last four
weeks the last three weeks in particular
but he's faced some tougher run defenses
in Tampa Bay the Jets he gets the 32nd
ranked defense in fn's Rush dvoa this
week in Carolina it's also a Carolina
offense that can't do anything so
there's just no reason to not expect a
ton of Rush attempts and for bejan to
recapture a little bit of the efficiency
he's lost since getting more volume all
right there you have it our six Fantasy
Playoff must starts Devonte Adams Z
Jones Derk Henry Matthew Stafford jayen
Reed
bejon
Robinson got a few minutes here before
we wrap up we'll get to as many chats as
we can quickly M Anderson says T Higgins
or Jordan Addison so these guys are
playing each other on Saturday I like T
as a player he hasn't really had any
actual good games this year obviously
Jake Browning stuff is not as good Leon
any thoughts on this one think it's
really close I kind of go back and forth
I slightly lean Higgins with the higher
team total he had a nice you know go up
and get it touchdown catch last week uh
did have sort of an obvious OPI called
on him so it didn't count but it's nice
to see Browning give him that sort of
chance and he is that type of player
that can make a play even when he's
covered so I lean a little bit towards
Higgins but again we have these guys
projected basically identically this
week ien Higgins too just yeah better
yeah better player I think right now
although I do like Jordan Addison long
term ice Ray 2 says Tai Chandler or
Devin single ter so Alexander Madison is
going to miss this game against the
Bengals due to his ankle sprain that
gives Tai Chandler the start here I
think they will have other in the mix
meanwhile we know what's going on with
the Texans I mean it could get real ugly
with no CJ strad we saw this offense
last year with Davis Mills and Davis
Mills was absolutely inept so just from
an offensive performance perspective
even with Nick Mullins I might feel
better about the Tai Chandler side here
but Leon what do you think yeah I'm with
you on the Tai Chandler side um you know
with Damen Pierce back and whatnot I'd
just rather take I think what's going to
be more Touches for Tai Chandler
Dizzy Wright says Jaylen Warren or Devon
aan so this would not be a question for
me no matter what if aan was healthy
doesn't sound great I mean picked up
another injac think designment to toe
Mike McDaniel wouldn't say if he's
playing or not I think he just got to
watch the injury report on this one
dizzy if anan's in and he's active I'm
playing him if he's not obviously then
you got to go Warren so I think pretty
straightforward one there let's go to m
Hernandez's back Brown's defense or Rams
defense so the S how sack rate has been
massive all year but Brown's defense has
been one of the best all year and Justin
Fields has a pretty high sack rate of
his own I think we're gonna have this
one pretty close in projection leonio we
come down to more I think of a gut feel
I feel a little bit better actually
about Browns defense just as the better
unit but definitely really close what do
you think yeah we have it close but I'm
with you I think the Browns Talent you
know super seeds stuff for me serves as
a good tiebreaker also you know both
these quarterbacks have done a little
bit better in terms of sack rate
recently but particularly Howell if you
look at like his splits like the first
half of games versus second half of
games um he's been much much better and
it there was also like a weird thing
with Washington last week where they
call a lot more run plays than they
have I I think that was just a weird
matchup with Miami not reading too much
into it but you do want them throwing a
lot if you're playing the Rams defense
so any risk of them not throwing quite
as aggressively would further tilt
things in favor of
Cleveland big body Cisco says Isaiah
likeley or Dallas Gard so Isaiah likeley
is my boy I love I love Isaiah likeley
he was so good in the preseason was so
good at Coastal Carolina I joke that
he's 90% Mark Andrews obviously that's
not true but he does have a pretty good
role on the other hand I'm not joking
when I say Alex Dallas Goddard is a much
much better player in a very good match
match up I think I would go Godard here
any disputes there Leon no disputes for
me I'll go to Black Joker who asks
Austin Eckler or Drake London I it's
pretty easy Eckler for me I know he's
been tough and the Chargers have a
brutal team total but I think if they
hope to do anything it's going to be
through Eckler in All Phases of the game
even if he gets a bunch of like short
catches whereas we just talked about how
much we like bejon and how much we
expect Atlanta to run this week I could
see London being fine on a per Target
basis and just really the floor isn't
there based on how this Atlanta offense
operates agree definitely eair for me
from it's Drew bz says Jared Goff or Joe
flacko so we've had some really bad golf
games lately like Jered goof games
lately we've had in a big big way I feel
like this is a spot for him to at least
get back on track and playing good
football he plays so much better at home
plays so much better in domes this game
has a total of 47 a half and the Lions
have one of the bigger team totals on
the week I have respect for what the
Broncos defense has done but yeah I
think it's gonna be Jared gof here uh
for me and I people shouldn't consider
Chicago defense as a pushover anymore on
the flacko stuff like not at all
Chicago's defense has been playing much
much better it's been against Bad
quarterbacks but I would still consider
flacko a bad quarterback at this point
in his career too so yeah GF for me you
want to take the next one Leon yeah josa
Reas asks Gardner mshu or Baker Mayfield
lots of quarterback questions this week
which I'm not surprised given just how
difficult of a year that it's been with
injuries I'm gonna slightly side with
Baker here it's tough because Green Bay
is a little bit of a run funnel but you
do have Tampa Bay three and a half Point
dogs and you know I just think baker has
more past TD upside with that connection
with Mike Evans then Gardner mshu does
and our projections see it that way too
giving him about one one and a half
point lead over Gardner
mshu last question we're going to do
here today comes from Boogie bot he says
puka naua or Chris olave so I know we
called Chris alve a uh start in the
bundles section and this is another
hashtag how hashtag humblebrag question
because puka and alve I think are two
really strong options this week but as I
said before I can't sit puka in this
spot I just I can't sit him in the dome
against the commanders with a Target
share so condensed and it looks like
tutu Atwell may even miss this game
which doesn't mean that much but just
more targets for puka so yeah I think
puka over a here all right fantasy
playoffs good luck to everyone out there
if you're watching this I assume you're
still in the playoffs are in the mix
well done good job by you appreciate you
all tuning in here each and every week
go out there and win your matchup for
everyone behind the scenes at bleacher
report for our friends at State
Farm